so speaking about
lying about everything here's kamala
harris who is waiting to be president
lying about of course what's happening
right here in florida
so these are issues that impact young
people because
as we all know your your right to vote
and the action of voting unlocks all the
other rights including same-sex marriage
including whether we're going to stand
up against a law that says don't say gay
basically
restricting kindergarten through third
grade teachers in florida to be able to
love openly
and teach what they believe is important
for people to understand
they're so deep in the [ __ ] they're
just so deep in the [ __ ] so first
off there is no law there is no law
across the country being pushed by
republicans stopping anyone from voting
there are some legislatures that are
trying to make it more sensible to vote
meaning you have to have an id to vote
you have to match signatures to vote
you've got to have a camera in the place
where they're counting the votes so
these people are lying about that and by
the way when they do that they're the
racists because the implication is that
somehow this is to stop black people
from voting and black people can't get
ids i know a couple black people they
all have ids because i always ask them
to see it
okay that's
so stupid it's all so stupid um but not
only that then of course what she says
there that somehow in florida we're
stopping teachers from loving who they
want to love
also nonsense also she knows it's not
called the don't say gay bill what i
mean you guys have been through this a
million times right it's about you
wouldn't want
a 45 year old teacher whether he was
male or female or male and female or
female and male or he was a they they or
be them or whether he was a furry or a
puppy or whatever you wouldn't want that
person or people's whatever they call
themselves talking to a six-year-old
about gender or sex or sexuality in a
room privately and not reporting it to
the parents that's what it's about but
kamala harris is a liar because she is a
democrat and that's all they've got at
this point i know that sounds very
partisan but show me a democrat who
isn't a chronic liar and i will gladly
put them on this show so what do you do
what do you do about all of that you
what you do is you stare it down and you
tell the truth
rod desantis
when they keep talking about don't say
gay they're implying that gay people
want gender idle and i don't think
that's true i think that's playing into
a stereotype i think the people that
want gender ideology in elementary
school are leftists that's the only
people that want it nobody else uh in
this country wants it
that is the distinction that is the
distinction i know a couple gay people
i'm married to one okay and they don't
want this nonsense i have to say you
know i was at the turning point
uh student action summit on sunday that
was yesterday and i gave my talk
somebody asked me a question about
florida and gay and don't say gay and
all that we're working on getting the
video we'll show it to you completely
unedited but i met many gay
conservatives there they are treated
equally like everybody else and what
does it mean even when they say that
they're conservatives these people they
basically just believe in reality they
believe in sanity that's what brings
them there and are they unlikely
conservatives or unlikely republicans
someone like me even i suppose i suppose
but if my choice is a roughly sane party
and a boat a bunch of woke insane
lunatics well then it's not even a
choice it's just not a choice so what
desantis said there is right and it's a
defense of gay people this is why gay
people should be the most outraged about
this gender nonsense what he's saying is
don't conflate the average gay person
who just wants to live their life
freely like every other citizen don't
conflate them with a leftist who wants
to groom these kids or whatever it is
that they want to do
and infect and completely uh destroy
these six-year-olds brains so they don't
know what is real right i mean don't let
them do that and that's not what most uh
gay people want it's not what most
straight people want it's not what most
sane people want it's what woke lunatics
and democrats want that really is true